the biggest question that i get asked is
should i quit my job should i quit my
job and do property i would usually say
no it depends i'm going to talk about
this video this guy actually asked me in
fact
i would have said no what was the
conversation we had um so
i asked the i told tamil to quit my job
he asked me how many deals i sold i said
none and then uh he said oh you got rent
to rent and i was like nope got none uh
but now we're here and
now he's doing well yeah worked out in
the end
he worked out in the end these guys are
awesome but generally speaking if you're
not sure whether to quit your job or not
i would usually say don't quit your job
there are advantages
to having a nine-to-five job whilst
starting out in property now i'm going
to talk a little bit about what those
are and hopefully this will help you out
and the thing is a lot of people
they learn about deal sourcing rent to
rent and they go that's amazing should i
just quit my job and go do that
and the thing is
you really
really don't have to you do not have to
quit your job to go and do property you
can do property part-time alongside your
job so the advantages to quitting your
job are very very small actually there's
very few advantages the only advantage
to quitting your job is that you just
hate your job so much that it's just
driving you insane it's making you mad
it's making you depressed if that's the
case
maybe you should quit your job but let
me tell you the advantages to having a
job number one
is you've got income coming in
and that income that's coming in is
going to mean that you aren't stressed
or desperate for money
when you're stressed
when you're desperate for money i have
to get a deal i need this to work then
when you're going about your business
going about you going about your daily
routines
you've got stressed and desperate
written across your forehead and
everybody will flee from you like you
are a leper okay so you don't want that
you want to be in a position where
you're you're coming from a position of
abundance rather than coming from a
position of desperation
number two
and by the way that's even more so if
you've got people depending on you
number two is when you've got a job it
actually helps you in property because
it's easier to get a mortgage
if you're getting a rent to rent it's
easier to pass through the references
having a job actually helps you rather
than hindering you in your um in your in
your property business
so the only reason i would quit your job
is if you're earning enough income
through property already that you can
afford to quit your job
now
some people here's a negative to staying
in the job some people get too
comfortable they're like i'm in my job
and they get really comfortable and then
they don't do anything so what i would
say is put a date
set a date in your diary whereby you are
going to earn more
in your property business than you are
in your normal job let me give you an
example let's say that you're making
two grand a month okay your income is 2
000 pounds a month you need to say right
in three months time from today
i want to be making
2 000 pounds a month
in my property business
now if after three months if you can
achieve that on top of your job maybe
get a couple rents and rent package and
sell one deal a month
it's not difficult if you can do that
then in three months time
that will mean
that your part-time business
is earning just as much or if not more
than your full time salary
when you're in a position when you're
part-time
business
okay your fortune business
is earning more money or the same as
your full-time job
then and only then generally speaking
should you quit your job
and then you can work full-time
on your fortune
so that's my general advice again there
are exceptions if your job's driving you
insane but it doesn't take long to start
a property business you absolutely do
not have to go full time to start
property business do it alongside a job
i hope that helps if you think about
quitting your job maybe you found this
video helpful give me a like hit the
like button subscribe for more videos
every single day i'll see you next time